en el último vídeo teníamos una
transformación lineal s que iba de un
subconjunto x de rn a un subconjunto de
rm y también teníamos una transformación
lineal t que iba del mismo subconjunto
de rm deje a un subconjunto de rlz
entonces nos preguntamos si podíamos
definir una transformación que nos
llevará directamente desde x hasta zeta
y en efecto si podíamos la llamamos la
composición de t con s y lo que hacía
era tomar un vector x en el conjunto en
el subconjunto x de rn un vector x en rn
y le aplicaban la transformación s para
llevarlo a un vector en rm y de ahí le
aplicaba la transformación t para
llevarlo a un vector nrl así que
definimos la composición de t con s de
esta manera y nos preguntamos si era una
transformación lineal dado que ese y
teherán transformaciones señales
checamos los dos requisitos y concluimos
que si era una transformación lineal
ahora como es una transformación lineal
podría representar mediante una matriz
de que sería de l por n pues será una
transformación que va de un subconjunto
de rn a un subconjunto de rl así que lo
que queríamos hacer era encontrar esta
matriz de y es lo que voy a hacer en
este vídeo entonces bien al principio
del vídeo pasado les había comentado que
como tener una transformación lineal se
podía representar mediante el producto
de una matriz con un vector así que
dijimos que te dé x era lo mismo que una
matriz b por el vector x donde la matriz
ve qué dimensiones tenía pues te va de
rm a rl de hecho aquí lo tengo escrito
así que la matriz b era de l por m
entradas
también también dijimos que ese de equis
o ese era una transformación lineal así
que ese de equis era lo mismo que una
matriz a por el vector x pero ahora ese
ese va de rn a rm
así que la matriz a era de m por n
entradas muy bien y recordemos
recordemos que nuestra definición de la
composición de t con s nos dice que esté
compuesta con s aplicada a un vector x
era lo mismo que t
aplicada a el resultado de aplicarle s a
el vector x
esto era nuestra definición pero ahora
bien quién es esto quién es este cachito
de aquí pues esto por lo que tenemos acá
es lo mismo que esta matriz a m por n
multiplicada por el vector x así que si
sustituyó eso y sustituyó eso aquí
obtengo que esto es lo mismo que te x
por el vector x pero ahora quien esté de
x pues es la matriz b por el vector x
así que si en vez de x usada por x esto
de allí eso de ahí es exactamente lo
mismo que
la matriz be
la matriz ve por
en la matriz a por el vector x así que
esto de aquí es sencillamente de
compuesta con ese aplicado al vector x
porque recuerden que lo que hace la
composición es toma un vector en rn toma
este vector x lo avienta a un vector en
rm mediante ese y luego avienta ese
vector en un vector
rl mediante té
así que bien por otro lado por otro lado
esto de aquí
estoy aquí dijimos que era igual a una
matriz d
a una matriz de multiplicada por el
vector x esto tiene que ser cierto pues
t compuesta con esa es una
transformación lineal así que debe
existir una matriz de que la represente
así que esto es cierto ahora lo que
quiero hacer es encontrar encontrar
explícitamente quién es esa matriz t
pues para encontrar la matriz de voy a
hacer lo que siempre habíamos hecho en
el pasado que es comenzar con la matriz
identidad y aplicarle la transformación
a cada columna de la identidad eso me va
a dar las columnas de la matriz de pero
de qué tamaño tiene que ser mi identidad
pues si nos fijamos la transformación t
compuesta con ese toma sus valores o más
bien agarra vectores toma vectores que
están en donde pues están en r n
toma vectores de rm y que esta x
pertenece a r n por lo tanto por lo
tanto tengo que considerar la matriz
identidad de n x en la matriz identidad
de n por n como se ve esa matriz pues
sencillamente es la matriz que tiene uno
en la diagonal tiene puros unos en la
diagonal y cero fuera de ella así que
sería 10 así hasta la enésima columna
1000 luego acá abajo también serían
puros ceros
hasta el enésimo renglón después acá en
la segunda columna sería 0 1 0
pero el tercer renglón tendría 001
10 bueno aquí sería un 1 de hecho
y acá serían puros ceros hasta este 1 de
aquí entonces bien le voy a aplicar este
compuesta con ese a cada columna de esta
matriz identidad noten que estos estos
de aquí son los vectores canónicos son
la base canónica de ere n muy bien
entonces si le aplico si le aplicó esta
transformación a cada columna de la
matriz identidad obtendré la matriz de
déjenme uso otro color
digamos celeste ok entonces la matriz de
va a ser igual a el resultado de
aplicarle la transformación t compuesta
con ese a cada columna de la matriz
identidad pero quien es la
transformación t compuesta con ese pues
es la matriz b
multiplicada por la matriz y
multiplicada por el vector x así que
esto es lo mismo
esto es lo mismo que ve
por a por la primera columna de la
matriz identidad que sería 10 después
puros ceros hasta esta última entrada
muy bien después la segunda entrada
sería la segunda columna perdón sería de
x x
0 10
así puro ceros
y así continuaría continuaría hasta ve
multiplicada por a multiplicada por 0 0
puro 0 puros ceros hasta la última
entrada y esa sería mi última columna de
la matriz de y se ve algo enredada pero
vamos a ver que no es cierto no están
enredos pues antes que nada antes que
nada recordemos que si tenemos una
matriz a de m por n multiplicada por un
vector x esto lo podría escribir como
sigue voy a escribir la matriz a como un
conjunto de sus vectores columnas así
que la matriz a es el vector columna a
uno vector columna a dos y cuántas
columnas tiene pues tiene n columnas así
que hasta el vector
y eso lo voy a multiplicar por el vector
x el vector x tiene que pertenecer a r n
para que esto tenga sentido así que esto
va a ser x 1 x 2 hasta x m
y quién es este producto de una matriz
por un vector pues sencillamente es x1
por el vector a 1 + x2 por el vector a 2
y así
así hasta x n por el vector a n
es decir el producto de esta matriz por
este vector es sencillamente la
combinación lineal cuyos coeficientes
son precisamente las entradas de mi
vector x así que bien tomando eso en
cuenta
tomando en cuenta quién va a ser mi
matriz de vamos a usar ahora verde
quién va a ser mi matriz de pues va a
ser
d
por a por el vector 10000 puros ceros
sólo una en la primera entrada pero
quién sería eso pues sería a uno por uno
que sería uno más a dos por cero más a
tres por cero así hasta a n por cero así
que lo único que me queda lo único que
me queda es uno por uno que
sencillamente aún así que es b por la
primera columna de la matriz a la
segunda columna va a ser b x
a uno por cero más a dos por uno más a
tres por cero y así hasta n por cero así
que aquí sólo sobreviviría solo estaría
a 2 y así lo mismo va a pasar con todas
las demás columnas hasta que lleguemos a
b x
por la enésima columna de a y eso es mi
matriz de bien pues creo que es un buen
momento para recapitular lo que hemos
hecho hasta ahora vamos a ver
empezamos empezamos con una
transformación ese que iba de un
subconjunto x en un subconjunto de x era
un subconjunto de r n
y yo era un subconjunto de r m
también nosotros sabíamos que s de x s
aplicada a un vector x era lo mismo que
una matriz a por ese vector x donde la
matriz a era de m por n muy bien también
también nosotros dijimos que teníamos la
transformación lineal t que iba del
subconjunto y que de nuevo es un
subconjunto de rm es el mismo que esté
en un subconjunto z que era un
subconjunto de r l y la transformación t
se podía representar mediante la matriz
b así que te dxt de un vector x era lo
mismo que la matriz b por el vector x
donde ahora la matriz b es de l por m
entradas muy bien entonces nosotros
definimos la composición t compuesta con
s que simplemente era aplicar ese y el
resultado aplicarle t y entonces a
partir de esto nosotros dijimos pues
esto es sencillamente
aplicarle té
y el resultado de aplicarle s al vector
x
así que era esto y esto esto era lo
mismo por esto de las matrices que tomar
la transformación t
tomar la transformación té y aplicársela
a la matriz a por el vector x y eso en
turno era lo mismo que la matriz b
multiplicada por el resultado de
multiplicar a la matriz a por el vector
x pero nosotros terminamos que como t
compuesta con s es una transformación
lineal esto era lo mismo que una matriz
de multiplicada por el vector x donde la
matriz de s está acá arriba déjenme la
vuelvo a escribir déjenme lo voy a
tratar de hacer con colores a ver si si
se entiende mejor d era lo mismo que la
matriz ve multiplicada por la primera
columna de la matriz a que representaba
s la segunda columna de the air' a la
matriz ve multiplicada por la segunda
columna de la matriz que representaba a
ese osea de la matriz a y así así hasta
la enésima columna que iba a ser la
matriz ve multiplicada por la enésima
columna de la matriz
y todo eso por el vector x muy bien y
noten que todo esto tiene sentido porque
la matriz be era de l por m entradas y
la matriz
era de m por l así que cada columna de a
tiene entradas cada uno de estos cada
allí pertenece a r m así que el producto
debe por cada uno de estas columnas si
está bien definido entonces esta fue la
representación matricial de t compuesta
con s pero nos gustaría ir un poco más
lejos nos gustaría que esto en realidad
fuera el producto de la matriz b con la
matriz a y en cierto sentido lo que
quiere hacer es muy simple lo único que
quiero hacer es poder cambiar estos
paréntesis y escribir esto como b
la matriz ve multiplicada por la matriz
a multiplicada por el vector x así que
quiero que esto de acá sea mi definición
de la matriz b por la matriz a y de
hecho nada me impide definir las cosas
así así que vamos a hacer eso vamos a
hacer una definición
definición si tengo una matriz b
es una matriz de l por m entradas y
tengo una matriz
tengo una matriz a que va a ser de m por
n entradas y de hecho a vamos a decir
que tiene la forma su primera columna es
el vector a uno su segunda columna es el
vector a dos
así hasta el vector columna a n
entonces entonces defino y esto es una
definición el producto debe por la
matriz a sencillamente como pues como
esto ve por la primera columna de a esa
es mi primera columna en el producto
luego ve por la segunda columna de a esa
es mi segunda columna en el producto y
así hasta por la enésima columna de a y
esa es mi enésima columna en el producto
así que puedo hacer esta definición y
tiene la gran ventaja de que entonces la
composición de transformaciones lineales
simplemente se representa como el
producto de las matrices que las
representan individualmente ahora quizás
en sus cursos de álgebra no reconozcan
esta definición del producto de matrices
pero vamos a ver que en realidad es una
definición bastante directa y podemos
hacer bastantes cálculos con ella si
tienen bastante paciencia incluso pueden
checar que esta definición coincida con
cualquier otra definición de producto de
matrices que ustedes
hayan aprendido antes así que bueno
ojalá esto les haya interesado y nos
vemos en el próximo vídeo